Texas governor Greg Abbott was in
southern Springs yesterday it's with us
now from Austin governor good morning
good morning charlie let me begin with
two questions do we know motive and do
we know if there was any connection
between the suspect now dead and the
church you know Charlie the way that the
evidence seems to be turning it looks
like there was a connection is something
that law enforcement officers are
continuing to look at but I think the
bottom line is this was not a random act
of shooting I don't think this church
was picked out at random I think there
was a purpose and intent that Devin
Kelley had and showing up at this
particular location obviously the
motivation behind it was completely
deranged as I'm sure you know it may
have reported this is a man who had some
mental health issues apparently long
before this even long before he enlisted
in the United States Air Force as I'm
sure you know he was dishonorably
discharged and so this is a person who
had mental challenges at the time this
happened but I do believe that there was
a connection between him and this
location that will come to light over
the coming days
governor what evidence do you have of
mental health challenges well obviously
I'm sure you know about his dishonorable
discharge and the reasons for that
discharge and that alone shows that he
was challenged there been some other
reports I would say loosely made not
confirmed about some mental health
issues before he entered into the United
States Air Force and so it's clear this
is a person who had violent tendencies
who had some challenges and someone who
was a powder keg seeming waiting to go
off then governor if you say he was a
powder keg and we do know that he was
court-martialed in 2012 on charges he
assaulted his spouse and child how was
he able to purchase an ar-15 in the
state of Texas sure well I will tell you
this and that is current law as it
exists right now should have prevented
him from being able to get a gun I can
tell you that before he made this
purchase he tried to get a gun
permit in the state of Texas and was
denied that permit and so under the
current system of federal law he should
have prevented from being able to make
this purchase how that got through the
cracks I don't have that information but
it's important to understand these are
the types of facts and issues that
investigators continue to look into and
and we will be able to have clear
answers to those questions in the coming
days
why was he denied he was denied a Texas
gun permit because of either answers or
the lack thereof that were provided in
his request to get a Texas gun permit
governor we're hearing stories that
eight members of one family lost their
lives on that Sunday morning going to
church so now we're at a place where you
get shot at a concert at a school at a
movie theater and now in church do you
now think that we have to think this is
a new normal in this country for the
citizens who live here well listen we
need to understand one thing and that is
in this country killing is illegal and
we've seen challenges in all different
kinds of ways as you know just last week
we saw a person use a truck to mow down
people in a bike lane as you know we've
seen bombings at concerts in London as
well as knife stabbings and so right now
we're just focusing on the guns what is
it going to take and and and that is
what you're focusing on it's important
that we all understand two very
important things and that is we have
evil that occurs in this world whether
it be a terrorist who uses a truck to
mow down bikers in New York City whether
it be a terrorist who uses bombs or
knives to stab people or other
terrorists who use vehicles whether it
be in Nice France or any other place in
the entire world who mow down people we
have evil that we have to confront and
hence the greatest response to evil is
what I encountered in Sutherland Springs
last night and that is the key focus of
these victims families that I got to hug
and hold and pray with they wanted one
thing they wanted a stronger connection
to God they wanted to be able to pray as
we shared a candlelight vigil and as
important that we go back to the
fundamentals of our faith-based nation
we all agree we all agree praying and
hugs are very good but what can we do to
keep these weapons out of people that
you bought you are saying yourself are
evil what can we do about that well and
the important thing is if you go back to
early times of this world to the times
of yesterday and last week evil exists
in this world and as what I'm gonna use
the words of the citizens as subtle Minh
Springs themselves and that is they want
to work together for love to overcome
evil and you do that by working with God
all right governor thank you very much
we're gonna have to leave it there but
of course this story continues and
continues and continues thank you so
much